[Music]
there were two concrete pylons topped
with lanterns and wrapped in strings of
blue christmas lights
they flanked the narrow dirt path off to
the left of the car
seeming incongruous against the black
drop of close moss hung trees
whose forms were starting to turn black
in the twilight
i'm guessing this is probably it evie
said folding up the directions she had
printed out as jonah turned the honda
and steered it between the pylons
after about 500 yards the path opened
out into a clearing where cars were
parked held her skelter around a cluster
of buildings
that included a small barn a glassed-in
greenhouse and an aluminum-sided garage
that housed a riding lawnmower
it looks like they started without us
finn said from the back seat
for the two-story main house was a blaze
with light and even from inside the car
the three of them could hear the
intermittent laughter and the
unmistakable cadence of the pogue's
fairy tale of new york
the only christmas song evie had ever
been able to stomach
you're lucky we came at all she said
smiling as she glanced across at her
husband in the driver's seat
jonah's been sick as a dog since
yesterday oh i'll make it
jonah said though even by the dim glow
of the dashboard panel he looked peaked
it's just a virus or something he nosed
the car onto an empty patch of ground
next to a fenced-in garden
then killed the engine he sat there for
a moment as though collecting his waning
strength
for some arduous task ahead well he
finally announced
happy holidays and so forth finn could
you grab that little bag behind evie's
seat
i'm going to get the pie and stuff out
of the back did you remember that other
present ev the baby one
yes dear evie laughed getting out of the
car and smoothing her plain black dress
over her thighs
it's behind the food i'll get it between
the three of them the various casseroles
and desserts and sleekly wrapped gifts
were conveyed from the car's hatchback
to the front of the house in the woods
where a silhouette was already framed in
the doorway waiting for them
as they approached the silhouette
resolved itself into the figure of ben
loomis one of their humble hosts
i hope we're not late evie said for she
had taken the lead in their march up the
flower line drive
ben waved a hand at her as he relieved
her of some of her burden
christ the others have only been here
about 15 minutes at the most
they've already gone through half the
booze though so you'd better get in
there hi finn hi jonah
before another quarter hour had passed
the three of them were ensconced in the
small but cozy house drinks in hand
jonah had only requested a half glass of
wine and made a quick circuit of the
room
wishing everyone a happy holiday
explaining his illness and his wish to
refrain from infecting others
then he retreated to a chair in the
corner of the living room casting an
apologetic glance at his wife
evie smiled reassuringly at him her own
wine glass filled to brimming
she and finn stood near the fireplace
which was festooned with plastic holly
and red candles
but contained no roaring christmas fire
the winter had been unseasonably warm
even for florida so ben or someone had
simply poked the television into the
grate
and cued up a dvd of a burning yule log
flickering on a continuous loop
it was only a small party but a raucous
one the pogues had given way to some
punk christmas compilation that someone
had brought
and the liquor was still flowing freely
evie glanced at jonah again
he had leaned back in his chair the
level of wine in his glass no lower than
it had been at first poor
his eyes were closed but he was still
awake for an amused smile played on his
lips and his head bobbed in time with
the music
evie felt bad for bringing him to the
party it wasn't only because he was sick
but also because this wasn't even his
crowd
they were all old college friends from
the theater department at uf
and other than finn who had ended up
working for the same company as evie
jonah barely knew them i can't believe
ben and mel want to live way out here
said finn taking a liberal slug of his
drink evie grind
oh come on it's not way out here why
there's a bait shop
strip club not five miles up the track
yeah i think i saw leatherface waving to
us from the porch as we passed that
finn said and they both erupted in
snickers
i think i can guess which you two are
laughing at melanie ben's wife of two
years
had approached across the living room
and was looking at them with mock
disapproval
her pregnancy which aside from christmas
was the main point of the celebration
was far enough advanced that her belly
made a hard shiny sphere of the midriff
of her red satin dress
she leaned forward across her bulk and
kissed their cheeks in turn
you look phenomenal mel abby said
melanie threw back her head and preened
yes just like a radiant hippopotamus and
don't think flattery is going to make me
forget that you were casting aspersions
on our laura ingalls experience out here
i'm curious mel finn said drawing his
thick eyebrows together in faux
seriousness
have you started hearing banjos perhaps
melanie laughed in spite of herself
put a sock in it fanner we're not gonna
feed you come on it's all on the table
she looked over at evie's husband jonah
are you going to eat with us or do you
fear you might vomit on the honey ham
jonah's eyes remained closed but a grin
split his pale face
i'll be all right i'm getting up now
they all moved toward the table and took
their places where their names appeared
on glittery red cards
evie was between jonah and finn ben sat
at the foot of the table and melanie at
the head
there were also two other couples andrew
and james and gail and robert
evie hadn't seen them for almost three
years but they all looked much the same
as they had at graduation
they were still young and vibrant and
almost unreal in the candlelight
ben cleared his throat then smirked when
several others at the table cleared
their throats and imitation of him
okay okay you know i'm not a big formal
speech guy but i just want to thank all
of you for driving out here to
deliverance country
to celebrate the holiday and the
impending continuation of my genetic
line
may i be worthy of the beautiful melanie
and whatever creature she may produce
he raised his glass salute pardon my
french
everyone raised their glasses in turn
their eyes shining with mirth and
conviviality
then they fell too with the comfortable
casualness of a group used to breaking
bread together
amid chewing and reaching in statements
like what's under this tinfoil does it
bite
and i made one with nuts and one without
because i remembered robert's
problem evie helped herself to turkey
and potatoes and some of the green bean
casserole finn had made
she looked at jonah's plate and saw that
it contained a single strip of pink ham
swimming in a bloody pool of cranberry
sauce her gaze flickered up at his face
and asked the unspoken question
are you sure you're all right and just
as wordlessly he answered
yes don't worry about me evie wasn't
worried exactly
jonah did look better under the warm
glow of the dining room chandelier
but not a great deal better once
everyone had eaten their fill and
started probing into the desserts
and once melanie had brought fresh
coffee out from the kitchen and poured
everyone a big steaming cup
ben looked around the table his eyes
glittering his papery palms rubbing
against one another in anticipation
do any of you know what this patch of
land used to be called he asked
no one did but they all knew the tone
and magic of the start of one of ben's
stories
so they all settled in turning their
bodies almost imperceptibly toward him
back in 1900 or somewhere around there
this place was just a farm in the middle
of this huge wilderness
totally surrounded by a swamp so just
like now then
andrew said you know better than to
interrupt me when i'm drunk and
pontificating
ben said pointing at andrew with a
waggling finger
anyway just a farm in the middle of
nowhere i don't think it had a name at
first but after a while people started
calling it birch fire
tell them why it was called that ben
melanie was leaning across the table
toward him at least as close as her
belly would allow
i'm going to tell them now birch was the
last name of the farmer who lived here
and his wife's last name too obviously
the fire part comes from the fact that
old birch built this big old
weird-looking incinerator on the
property and he was always burning
things in it
wait a minute how would anyone know that
i thought you said there was no one else
around
gail held a fork full of pecan pie
topped with whipped cream halfway to her
mouth
dammit whose story is this ben said and
the table boiled over into giggles
when the tipsy laughter had subsided ben
leaned in again
lowering his voice into a scary vincent
price register
people could smell the burning for miles
around they all said it smelled like the
fires of hell
with just a touch of smoldering flesh
for little added spice
finn interjected ben went on ignoring
him
the word kinda got around that burch and
his wife were maybe up to some foul
deeds
murder or some type of witchcraft so a
few of the old timers along the outer
edge of the swamp
they decided to bring their guns and
investigate knight had fallen fully
outside
a complete country darkness with no
ambient glow from streetlights or other
houses
a darkness like a black curtain evie
could see all of them sitting around the
table
reflected back at her from the black
windows faces smirking but wrapped and
almost pagan
they crept onto the farm one night with
their guns and lanterns after the
birches were asleep
and right away they knew that horrible
smell was coming from that strange
incinerator contraption out behind the
barn
so they all went up to it and raised
their lanterns and had a look inside
everyone at the table was silent now
they're half-eaten desserts still on the
plates in front of them
their coffee growing cold the only sound
was the occasional cesarous of wind
through the thicket of trees outside
the droning were of crickets ben had
paused in his story for so long that the
silence began to feel as enormously
pregnant as melanie's womb
and even then he let it hang over the
table a little longer
milking the suspense for all it was
worth it was a talent that had served
him well on the stage
was still serving him well if the
reviews in the theater magazines were to
be believed
at last he spoke his eyes like twin
candle flames shining from puddles of
black oil
at first they couldn't tell exactly what
it was they were looking at
a lot of it was just ash or twisted
black shapes
but then they started poking around in
there and by the light of the lanterns
they finally figured out what old farmer
birch had been burning
tell them what it was ben melanie's
pretty round face was taught with the
pleasure of the tale he was telling
in school mel had always taken great
delight in the morbid
and evie was strangely comforted that
even her impending motherhood had not
changed her
fetuses ben said drawing his head back
and raising his eyebrows
but not just regular fetuses they were
almost human
but then again not quite james snorted
laughter but abruptly stopped when his
boyfriend andrew poked him in the ribs
when they saw the remains of all those
burned things then the men knew for sure
what they were up against
which was what exactly finn said
inadvertently whispering to match ben's
tone
there's an old seminal legend melanie
said picking up the story as smoothly as
if she had rehearsed it
about a creature that lives in these
woods no one has ever really seen it but
sometimes people could hear it in the
woods at night
something very big moving very slowly
and steadily almost dragging itself
through the undergrowth
every now and then someone would catch a
glimpse of something through the trees
something huge and shiny wet and white
like something that lived underground
and never saw the sun
a fat white slimy thing like a larva
robert curled his lip and disgust where
do you guys come up with this stuff
please hold all questions until the end
of the story melanie said
again as if she had rehearsed it
occurred to evie that mel might have
been practicing this shtick for weeks
eager to tell them this tale indeed it
might have been the whole point of the
party
christmas and baby be damned they called
it hot kitaate
it means white father or pale sire mel
said
a quivering smile teasing the corners of
her mouth
it was said to propagate itself by
choosing human women to carry its
offspring
is there something you're trying to tell
us mel finn said glancing at her belly
she flashed him a smirk that was where
birch's wife came in she said
anyway the men knew there was nothing
they could do to help the birches
except release them from their horrible
suffering
ben drained the last of his wine from
the glass they put the farm to the torch
he said with birch and his wife still
inside
and then it really was a birch fire mel
said the perfect capper to the
performance
the cherry on top of the sundae anyone
want more coffee
the tension dissipated from around the
table like air being released from a
balloon
and soon the wine and nerves were giving
rise to laughter in conversation that
seemed a little louder than it needed to
be
after mel had retreated into the kitchen
evie turned to ben
what kind of [ __ ] story was that she
said with a grin
he raised his hand every word of it is
true i swear to wikipedia
he offered her the wine bottle and at
first she shook her head but then she
relented
it was a party after all she was pretty
buzzed but it was a pleasant buzz
the incinerator thing is still there you
know ben wasn't looking at her
concentrating on pouring the wine
without spilling it evie's eyes widened
what we didn't see anything like that
when we drove up
it's behind the barn like i said in the
story we built our barn where the birch
one used to be
evie cocked an eyebrow how come the
vigilantes didn't burn that too
oh they tried to ben said flames kept
going out
damnedest thing he grinned wickedly at
her
after mel opens her presents maybe we
can all go outside and see it
and so after the food and drink had been
cleared away evie found herself sitting
in a chair by the fireplace
listening to the howls of laughter as
mel opened the wildly inappropriate baby
gifts everyone had brought
including a pacifier with vampire fangs
and a tiny black t-shirt bearing the
slogan mommy shakes me
evie laughed too but she couldn't stop
thinking about ben's crazy story
wondering if that infernal barbecue was
really still out there and the inky
blackness beyond the windows
standing there is a mute testament to a
cursed madness
once mel had torn through her pile of
gifts and more wine had been consumed
ben suggested the whole party should
drive out to town to see some christmas
parade with fireworks
and most everyone agreed immediately and
began squabbling about who was still
sober enough to pilot ben's ancient
chevy suburban
evie glanced over at jonah who still
looked like death warmed up
and then over at finn who was looking at
her with strange intensity that she had
been noticing a lot in the past few
months
you don't mind if i go ahead and crash
early do you jonah was stretched out on
the loveseat his shoes abandoned on the
rug
i'm still not feeling very well ben
looked down at him drunkenly stern
if you must be a complete and utter
killjoy then by all means
we gave you the first bedroom at the top
of the stairs if you want an actual bed
to die in
jonah smiled weekly thanks i might take
you up on that
i guess i'll stay here with him evie
said in case he needs anything
she knew he probably wouldn't he would
likely just fall asleep until
mid-morning
i'll stay too finn said a little too
quickly
no offense but watching the world's most
inbred christmas parade doesn't sound
like a way to spend an evening
oh i see us country folks aren't good
enough for you latte sipping urban types
ben sniffed
that's fine eat my food drink my booze
ogle my pregnant wife and mock me go
ahead
finn laughed and ebby took ben by the
arm i want to see that oven thing
she said quietly enough that jonah
wouldn't hear have you got a flashlight
ben looked at her for a second as if he
had no idea what she was talking about
oh oh yeah i forgot about that there's a
flashlight in the cabinet over the stove
but be careful if you go out there
the woods are full of snakes and bears
and who knows what else
i'll be careful she turned and saw finn
watching her a bright glitter in his
eyes
after the inebriated party had left the
roar of the suburban's engine quieting
the crickets as it faded into the
distance
evie and finn both slightly wobbling on
their feet managed to pack jonah
upstairs and get him settled under the
dull red counter pain in the spare
bedroom
he smiled vaguely in their direction
then slipped into sleep
his partially blocked sinuses turning
his breathing into the rooting snuffle
of a warthog
evie quietly closed the bedroom door and
followed finn down the stairs
you're really going out there to see
that thing finn was watching her as she
stood on her tiptoes and poked through
the upper cabinets
you're coming to hero she answered
glancing over her shoulder at him
that way when a bear comes it can eat
you while i run away ha ha
he crossed his arms and tilted his head
to one side ben's probably full of [ __ ]
you know there's nothing out there
evie found the flashlight and flicked it
on and off a few times in finn's face
i guess we'll see about that don't make
me call you a chicken
the night had gone pleasantly cool the
air just crisp enough to cause sharp
tingles on the tips of their noses and
fingers
the ground floor of the main house was
still brightly lit and for a while finn
and evy were able to remain in the
charmed golden glow
even as the woods closed in around them
the barn was a small
neat structure of freshly painted blue
wood really a barn only a name behind it
lay a cone of shadow that stretched all
the way to the tree line
a dead zone where almost nothing was
visible
the crickets had resumed their chirping
and somewhere close by evie could hear
the lap of water against a bank
there were also other forest sounds
punctuating the relative stillness
the occasional hoot of an owl the far
away rustle of underbrush as some
nocturnal animal went about its business
evie's skin prickled slightly from the
chill as well as from anticipation
she turned on the flashlight in its
feeble glow she could pick out the edge
of ben and mel's vegetable garden
in an off-white cylindrical shape that
might have been a water pump
the dark forms of cars were pressed in
all around oppressive as the trees
and evvy was slightly disturbed that it
took more than a few minutes before she
could identify jonah's honda
the knight was rendering the familiar
ambiguous she could hear finn breathing
very close beside her his foot falls as
loud as rifle shots
at last the farthest reach of the
flashlight beam splashed across a
misshapen pile of blacker shadow
and evie's heartbeat quickened in time
with her pace
finn fell behind for a moment and then
she heard him trotting to catch up
whispering is that it into her ear and
sounding as though he was screaming the
incinerator was nothing impressive to
look at
it was really no more than a hastily
assembled pile of flat stones a bit
taller than a person
with a raggedy almost square opening
about three quarters of the way up from
the bottom
a few of the topmost stones looked
broken off or missing and even in the
negligible illumination from the
flashlight
evie could see the harsh blackening
along part of the surface exactly as if
the structure had once caught fire
it even still had a bare whiff of a
burnt smell about it a dusty black smell
dry and sharp
but underneath that evie thought she
could smell something else something wet
and secretive
guess ben was telling the truth after
all finn muttered under his breath
and evie wanted to tell him to be quiet
but she was too distracted by the feel
of his body heat
practically pressed up against her left
side and the soft wuff of his breath on
her cheek
leaning forward she shined the
flashlight into the opening and peered
inside
it was black as a hell mouth in there
and the secret wet smell was more
pronounced
so much so that her nose wrinkled
involuntarily
the hole seemed to go deeper into the
structure than it at first appeared
though in the darkness it was impossible
to see any remnants of what had once
been burned there
ben's story notwithstanding it had
probably been nothing more nefarious
than a few pork ribs but still
ebby straightened up again noticing as
she did that finn seemed very close now
the wine and cologne scent of him nearly
drowning out the damp burn smell from
the incinerator
evie realized she was more than a little
drunk and with this realization came a
sudden crystalline revelation
an understanding of finn's closeness his
intense stares at the party
the strange way he had been looking at
her at work for the past few months
maybe she'd been too wrapped up in her
life with jonah to see it but now she
did
well finn said still keeping his voice
low as if not to disturb the pagan gods
of the forest
was it all you hoped it would be and
more she turned the flashlight beam into
his face
and he squinted but didn't look away
from her finn
she said and she wasn't sure what words
she had planned to say after that
but as it happened it didn't matter
because at that moment he kissed her
somewhat hesitantly his soft lips
tasting of grapes and icing sugar
then he pulled back his eyes almost
comically wide as if they were shocked
at what the lower half of his face had
done
under their lack surveillance they
stared at each other for a moment
finn's features still bathed in the
shaky partial glow of the flashlight
their breathing gone ragged as if they'd
both been running
evie felt something very strange come
over her perhaps only the shock of the
situation mixed with the potent effects
of the wine
but perhaps something else as well for
some reason she flashed on jonah and his
pitiful sick snores
as he lay in the guest room upstairs and
she suddenly thought of things about him
that she'd never consciously thought
before
like the way one eye drooped when he
looked at her the way he hummed between
his teeth when he was nervous
the way he always pulled stupid faces
when they were making love
as if he could never quite take the
endeavor seriously
she felt distantly guilty for thinking
these things but the impressions
nevertheless came to her in a hot wave
of emotion
that also carried with it the sudden
appreciation of the pale sloping angles
of finn's face
the way his dark hair fell and just so
wisps across his forehead
the way his silver green eyes considered
her with open longing
the sweet animal smell of him
overpowering her better judgment
short-circuiting her rational brain and
plugging straight into the reptilian
with no further consideration she
touched the side of his face with her
free hand
and leaned in pressing her lips against
his hard
she could feel their heartbeats tripping
and crazy jazz improv rhythms as their
bodies met
when she backed off a seeming eternity
later she felt as though she might lose
her balance
and steadied herself by placing her hand
on the lip of the incinerator's opening
the burned stone felt powdery and yet
oddly slick beneath her fingers
finn's gaze dropped i didn't mean for
that to happen he said his voice almost
muffled
as if they were facing each other inside
a fabric bag
evie willed her heart to stop racing
breathe slowly through her nose
it's all right i think we're both a
little drunk that wasn't all it was of
course but normalcy had to be restored
the incident closed off from external
reality yeah i guess we are
the green of his eyes seemed to darken
the green of the surrounding forest
at twilight but then the illusion passed
did you see what you wanted to see
evie had almost forgotten about the
incinerator poised there beside her
supporting her wobbling legs
yeah i guess i and then there was a
strange sound from the woods
not a loud sound but somehow tremorous
more felt than heard
finn looked at her his eyes round and
ebby's heart wheezed to maximum capacity
again
threatening to burst through her chest
the sound came again
a low dragging sound a belly crawling
sound evie first thought of a big gator
crawling out of the swamp
its scaly hides shimmering black in the
moonlight but what she really thought of
in the part of her mind where her
consciousness would not go was a blind
white wet thing
pulling itself through the fallen leaves
with its pulse pink appendages like
segmented beetle legs
the air temperature seemed to have
plunged 15 degrees and she shuddered
let's get back to the house finn was
clearly frightened his pale face gone
paler still in the silent movie flicker
of the flashlight she still held in her
trembling hand
yeah evie loosened her grip on the
incinerator opening but for a moment it
seemed that her hand was reluctant to
let go
it felt like there was a 20-pound
dumbbell at the end of her arm
i shouldn't drink so much it's making me
stupid she thought
though that was just the innocuous mask
over the face of her real thoughts
and she yanked her hand away with such
force that she nearly toppled to the
ground
would have in fact had finn not clumsily
caught her the darkness around her was
spinning a little now the stars overhead
like white streaks spiraling into a
drain
she pointed the flashlight in the
direction she thought the house lay in
though the barn was evidently blocking
her view of it because she could see
nothing but shadows on top of shadows
come on she whispered comforted by the
warmth of finn's body beside her
he gripped her free hand but then pulled
away with a sharp cry of disgust
what she said and then she felt it a
small damp weight on the back of her
hand
ticklish and taunting and she brought
her hand into the circle of light
and saw a plump white caterpillar or
maggot crawling around there on her skin
as if looking for a place to burrow into
its tiny stubbed legs moving in
disturbing synchrony
with a screamy exhale she flung her hand
backwards back toward the incinerator
where the creature had probably emerged
from
the incinerator she could no longer see
she felt the weight of the thing
separate from her flesh and even though
she could hear the fat plop as it landed
in the underbrush behind the barn
the sensation of it crawling there on
the back of her hand remained
seeming to spread up her arms and neck
to her face like a fast-acting rash
and it was all she could do to keep from
dropping the flashlight and falling to
the ground
howling and scratching at herself until
her skin was flayed raw
give me the flashlight of finn's
unsteady voice came stuttering out of
the darkness
and after a moment she felt his fingers
prying it loose from her death grip
and then his hand wrapped itself around
her uncontaminated one and pulled her
forward
and though the night was sightless
disorienting she let herself be led
trailing behind the guttering flashlight
beam as it shined upon nothing
it might have been a minute or an hour
when they arrived back at the house with
its obscenely illuminated windows
and as they stumbled across the
threshold moving from the brisk swirling
chill of the outdoors to the gently
heated interior
evie felt a surge of nausea and
staggered on her feet
certain she would vomit she dropped
finn's hand and leaned forward over her
knees but nothing came
though a slick of cold sweat had broken
out all over her skin
she was either very drunk or had caught
whatever jonah had
finn was standing over her the lit
flashlight forgotten in his hand
and he was asking her if she was alright
but she could only register his voice at
a distance
a crackling radio signal from a faraway
satellite
at last she straightened still feeling
sick but beginning to get on top of it
the hand the caterpillar had touched
still felt diseased leprous
and almost without realizing it she let
it hang motionless by her side
a useless appendage with her other hand
she signaled to finn
telling him she was okay telling him to
back off a little
he did but only a step or two without
taking his eyes off her he flipped the
switch on the flashlight and set it down
on the kitchen counter
she opened her mouth experimentally
feeling the nausea return for a moment
and then pass
before she ventured to speak what the
[ __ ] just happened
finn combed his fingers through his hair
i'm getting another drink you want one
he turned toward the refrigerator christ
now she watched him as he poked among
the bottles and then poured himself a
generous slug of whiskey
his hand shaking slightly he looked
different somehow
his profile sharper his pale skin
fragile like a ceramic figurine
he had a strange electric aura about him
that had not been there before
as she stood there and watched him drink
she wanted to ask again what
had happened out there and the question
had traveled most of the way up her
larynx when suddenly jonah snored
upstairs
an impossibly loud strangled intake of
breath and evie nearly screamed
finn was staring at her now ringed green
eyes watery with alcohol
i'm sorry he said huskily there was
something out there
she hadn't known she was going to say it
but once she had she knew it was the
truth
she cast an apprehensive glance toward
the windows through which she could see
nothing at all
it was nothing an alligator we're drunk
the air around him seemed to be buzzing
and evie could feel the creeping spread
of the worm sickness pulsing in time
with the signal
shouldn't the others be back by now it
seemed very late
to her closer to dawn than twilight
though she couldn't see the clock from
where she stood
we weren't out there that long finn said
but he looked uncertain
and seemed reluctant to look at his
watch as though confirming the time
might make concrete the whole experience
fix it in the continuum of actual events
i should check on jonah she said she
didn't really want to
didn't want his sleeping oblivious form
to silently judge her for her
transgressions
but she felt it was her duty ev
finn stepped forward and put his hand on
her arm the one so far unaffected
and still the contact made the nausea
rise again made her taste something
sharp like ozone in the back of her
throat
she swallowed hard and met his gaze as
he said stay with me tonight
for a long moment she didn't register
what he had said the nerves where the
larva's feet had touched had spread and
branched and touched other nerves
and now she felt herself filling with
inner crossing wet strings
that tied themselves in slimy knots
around her organs
slipping into crevices and roosting
there nestling bursting growing
under this onslaught finn's request
seemed trivial idiotic
and yet at last understanding filtered
through and allowed her to formulate a
response
i can't they'll all be coming back
everyone will know
even as she said it she wondered if ben
and beautiful pregnant mel and any of
the others would ever be coming back
if they had just driven off into the
woods as though leaving a stage set
as if they had never existed at all
perhaps they had heard a sly dragging
whisper through the underbrush
caught a glimpse of sickening sunless
white in the rear view mirror
huge and deliberate and gaining right
before
it touched me she said and then she
looked at finn
startled as though the voice had come
from someone else
it felt as though it had like some other
thing had lodged in her gullet and was
controlling her body like a
ventriloquist controlled the dummy
finn stared hard at her his brows
furrowing with worry
what it was just a caterpillar or
something ev jesus
you're drunk you should get some sleep
forget what i just said
come on let's go check on jonah she
looked at him again
feeling time stretched thin as spider
silk but then she went forcing her alien
body to move her reeling mind forward
finn was right behind her his hand
hovering just inches from her elbow
quivering to touch her but refraining
the upstairs hallway was dark save for
the soft yellow glow of a single wall
sconce that pushed shifting shadows into
the corners
the door to the room jonah slept in was
slightly ajar as they had left it
earlier and evie pushed it in with her
hand
glimpsing the silhouette of her
husband's sleeping form outlined in
moonlight
from the window she couldn't hear him
breathing now and she wondered if he
might be dead
or worse might be lying there watching
her keeping very still so that he could
pounce on her when she approached
it was a bizarre notion and she shook
her head as if to dislodge it
are you gonna be all right finn was
still not touching her but he leaned
very close to her as he spoke
yes even to her own ears her voice
sounded distant disembodied
i'm going to bed i'll be just across the
hall if you need me
his eyes were hooded in the dimness
appearing as two holes with bright
yellow sparks within
she nodded then pushed the room door
wider and stepped over the threshold
finn hesitated she could feel his gaze
boring into her
exciting the larval molecules that were
now infesting her entire body
appropriating it for their own purpose
then finn said good night awkwardly
and turned away from her disappearing
into the cavern of his own room
though he left the door half open evie
closed her own door
cutting off the world outside containing
what was inside the room inside of her
the moonlight was sufficient for her to
make her way across the room without
stumbling
though she gave the bed supporting
jonah's sleeping body a wide berth
still partially convinced that he was
staring at her was able to detect the
scent of betrayal and contamination upon
her
instead she curled up in the overstuffed
chair near the window
drawing her knees up to her chest jonah
remained still but now she thought she
could discern a very faint whispering
sound that might have been his breathing
and she fancied she could see two white
pinpricks in the darkness where his eyes
would have been
regarding her from the shadows his fins
had evie placed her fingers across her
stomach
and pushed inward ever so slightly yes
she thought she could feel it there
a shifting something that was not of her
body the seed of the interloper
she closed her eyes and for a moment she
was outside in the crisp pine scented
arrogant
her hand clutching the concrete lip of
the strange furnace
finn's green eyes enormous in her vision
his lips pressed into hers
that was how it had fooled her as she
realized that white flesh dweller in the
woods
it had used the form of her dearest
friend to impart its hellish progeny
to make her its vessel it had chosen her
seduced her
she felt a fluttering beneath her
fingers deep inside her belly
and then she was sure that the flesh
there began to swell
she almost called out for finn but how
could she trust him after what he had
done
after what he had conveyed to her what
if he appeared at the door and she could
see it behind his eyes the white fleshy
form of the thing
watching her mocking her and of course
jonah would be no help either
jonah ostensibly ill ostensibly sleeping
but really lying there a few feet from
her watching her too
through the sharp twinkles that had once
been his eyes he knew what she had done
knew and judged her belly stretched
larger
enough that her interlocked fingers
began to pull apart and she shuddered at
the feel of the parasitic weight and the
squirming movements of the creature
drawing her knees even closer to her
torso in the hope that she could crush
it in its stolen incubator
but it seemed that this only made the
creature push back harder against her
and she cried out in pain though she at
least had enough presence of mind to jam
her fist into her mouth to suppress the
sound
to keep finn from coming to keep jonah
from feeling the satisfaction
suddenly the room was awash with light
from the window and outside a great
rumbling sound arose like the combined
roar of all the hybrid demon children
emerging from the ground
bent on revenge they were coming for her
she knew that
all of those twisted burned bodies
squirming and muleing through the
undergrowth
followed by their sire larval father
conquer a worm
she couldn't let herself be tricked
again breached again she couldn't end up
like mrs burch
not if she could do something to prevent
it the bright light from the window was
extinguished but evie barely noticed as
she bolted from her chair
the creature growing huge inside her and
threatening to burst from her belly
distantly she heard a creak of bed
springs and her husband's sleep
thickened voice saying her name
but she was already at the bedroom door
and out in the hallway
and then finn's startled face appeared
in her peripheral vision as he poked his
head out from his own room
in toning evie weight but she was past
him and down the stairs
she heard him following panicked
footfalls not far behind
but she ran on regardless fire will
cleanse
she thought the same fire that had
destroyed the beast's former children
would also destroy the one she carried
and destroy her with it shatter the
vessel as she ran through the kitchen
her gaze fell on the red candle lighter
that had been used to light the candles
at dinner
an eternity ago and she snatched it up
in a fluid motion
trying to ignore the crawling and
gnawing of the furious spawn inside her
body
finn shouted her name again somewhere
but it was nothing to do with her now
cool air slapped her in the face as she
tore open the back door and streaked out
into the night
other voices reached her ears then
calling to her crying out an alarm
it occurred to her that the voices were
familiar somehow but they belonged to a
life she no longer knew
they called for a person that was no
longer her but simply the shell and
puppet of a controlling monstrosity
it was dark as she ran for the barn and
what lay beyond it
but she was sure-footed and did not
stumble perhaps the touch of the
creature had given her something of its
nightborne essence
the furnace loomed ahead almost seeming
to glow with all the cleansing blazes of
the past
and effie almost thought she could see
the hideous offspring there hundreds
strong
writhing and shrieking in the flames the
vision nearly made her stop and turn
back
but she knew she had to do this she
could not allow it to get started again
she heard rustling in the leaves and
fallen pine needles
as of a thousand insect legs and she
knew the thing was bearing down on her
it would have to be done quickly she
reached the furnace and placed her hand
the one that had first been contaminated
by the evil on the lip of the opening
when she flicked the candle lighter to
life the tiny orange light seemed to
illuminate the world
and out of the corner of her eyes she
thought she saw something massive
tall as treetops white and glistening
wet in the glow
its shadow fell across her she pressed
the flame to her flesh
and waited for it to purify her
the sky was just starting to darken as
pamela runyon left the store
a bag in each hand she had parked as
close as the crowded lot had allowed
since the accident which her mind always
insisted on enclosing in quotes
she hadn't felt much like walking far
the lights around the parking lot were
beginning to flicker to life
as she stowed her bags in the trunk she
dropped her keys
swore and stooped to pick them up she
heard a car pull into the space next to
hers but she didn't pay much attention
an owl hooted somewhere in the trees
nearby
pamela straightened up keys in hand and
then she was grabbed from behind
she opened her mouth to scream but a
hand clamped over it
and she just had time to think what long
fingers the hand had
before she felt a sharp blow to the back
of her head after that
nothing it was dark but she could see a
little from a faint green glow to her
left
an alien light she moved her head and
groaned at the pain
there was a rush of noise in her ears a
feeling of movement
there were figures very close hulking in
the shadows just at the edges of her
vision
at least two figures maybe more pamela
had
the impression of large yellow eyes of
something like fur
of strange protrusions above the heads
that could have been horns
confused and unsettled by this
disjointed but vivid nightmare
she rolled over and pulled her sweater
around herself wondering where her
husband was
had he got up to go to the bathroom
thinking he would be back soon she
closed her eyes again and was soon
unconscious
when pamela came fully awake some
unknown span of time later
the first thing she was aware of was
darkness and the close pungent smell of
hay
after a few moments she also began to
focus on sounds
there were furtive small rustlings in
the corners which might have been bugs
or mice
and there were louder more deliberate
sounds which were definitely made by
something much larger
these other noises seemed to be coming
from somewhere below her
her head throbbing pamela tried to move
but found that her wrists and ankles
were bound with something that felt like
thick rope
she tugged at her bonds but they had
been expertly knotted and held tight
trying to keep quiet in case someone was
nearby she struggled hard for a few
minutes
thrashing her arms and legs trying to
loosen the ropes
it was hopeless panting she settled back
against the misshapen mattress she was
lying on
she then realized that she was naked but
covered with a scratchy thin blanket
that smelled musky like a horse
her heart was beating hard in her chest
but otherwise she felt oddly calm
detached
she twisted her head wincing at the pain
which seemed less acute than before but
still raw
above her she could just make out the
faint outline of what might have been a
high curtained window
with moonlight filtering unevenly around
the edges
she wondered almost idly if anyone
outside would hear her if she screamed
before she could find out pamela heard a
heavy rhythmic creaking
like the sound of footsteps on a wooden
staircase as the creaking grew louder
she also thought she could hear a
regular but muffled rasp of breath
in and out like the wheeze of an
asthmatic
once she had realized the implications
of these sounds her strange calm
suddenly ramped up into pulse-pounding
terror and panic
and she began to struggle again
violently this time her limbs contorting
and inhuman spasms in her desperate
attempts to get free
she grunted and swore and screamed
thrashing against the lumpy mattress
the blanket was thrown off her body and
she felt the nip of a cool night
breeze on her skin which pushed her to
struggle harder
let me go she said into the darkness
which was now laden with an obvious
presence
she wanted her words to sound fierce and
fearless and authoritative
instead they came out as a pitiful
squeak she could see the figure now
dimly as it seemed to emerge slowly from
the floor
her frenzied mind took a few long
seconds to determine that it was
actually climbing up into the room from
below
either from a staircase or a ladder
another few seconds elapsed before she
put all the clues together
and deduced that she was being held
captive in the loft of a barn
the sparse moonlight from above
illuminated only a vague silhouette
but as the figure drew close pamela
could plainly see
that this was not a normal person if
indeed it was a person at all
its dimensions were roughly human-like
and it appeared to walk on two legs and
to have a roundish head
but there the similarities stopped there
was a flash of large golden eyes
and horns or antennae protruding from
the crown of the creature
its shoulders were fairly narrow like a
person's but they flared oddly out and
down
giving it the appearance of armlessness
pamela tried to curl her trust and
vulnerable body as far away from the
approaching thing as the ropes would
allow
please she said not knowing where to
look on the creature
and finally focusing on the yellow
glints that might have been its eyes
please don't hurt me i won't won't what
she realized she'd been trying to think
of something some bargain she could make
in exchange for her freedom
but what could she give this creature
what did it want from her
i won't tell anyone about you she said
which seemed meaningless
but was all she could think of the
creature didn't answer
it was very close to the edge of the
mattress now and as pamela watched in
horror
it leaned down toward her she wanted to
turn her face away
not see what this thing looked like and
she whimpered and cried
but in the end she kept looking couldn't
tear her eyes away from it
its face was oddly flat and covered with
something soft
upon closer inspection this covering
proved to be feathers
which were mostly white but turned to a
darker brown around the edges
there were indeed huge round discs for
eyes glowing yellow in the dimness
the pupils fixed and black and staring a
tiny pearly beak jutted from where the
nose would be on a human being
pamela wanted to scream but the sound
died in her throat
the creature was looking at her but its
eyes did not move
its expression did not change in a swift
motion it reached down and picked up the
blanket from the floor
and placed it back over her with what
she could see now
were perfectly normal human arms which
had previously been concealed under a
long poncho
i'm sorry about this the creature
whispered it was a woman's voice
pamela realized with a start although
she couldn't determine from where the
voice had issued
since the creature's face had not moved
why have you brought me here
pamela asked her heart finally resuming
a normal beat
she felt much better now that she was
covered up again and now that she knew
this thing could talk
could feel sympathy the bird woman
didn't answer right away
instead she sat down on the floor
crossing her legs
her face now on a level with pamela's i
brought you something to eat
she said i'm sorry about the ropes but i
can't undo them
pamela tried to force herself into a
sitting position but only succeeded in
straining her limbs painfully
she gave up what do you want from me i
don't have anything to give you
she suddenly remembered waking up
earlier in the van or whatever it had
been
there had been others at least two more
besides this one
there are more of you aren't there yes
down below
the creature produced a bowl from
somewhere under the pancho and stirred
its contents with a wooden spoon
you have to eat now keep up your
strength strength for what
in the dimness pamela could see the
spoon coming toward her
laden with some kind of colorless mush
she was hungry but she had to admit it
didn't look very
appetizing what is it just a stew
eat it the creature pushed the spoon at
pamela's mouth
and pamela grudgingly took a bite the
stuff was gritty and fibrous
and tasted slightly of maple not good
but not as horrible as she was expecting
after a few more bites she looked up
into the creature's stoney face
you're not planning to kill me are you
it seemed a silly question
why would they be feeding her and trying
to keep her warm if they were intending
to kill her but then
why else would they want to kidnap her
the bird woman looked down into the bowl
stirring at the mush absently no
her voice was still muffled as though
she was speaking through a mouthful of
sand
she looked up at pamela again finish
your food
pamela opened her mouth to receive the
spoon and neither of them spoke again
when the bowl of mush was empty the
creature got to its feet and with the
last glance down at the prisoner
turned and made its way back down the
ladder
pamela lay back against the mattress
shivering despite the blanket
she wanted to think that this was all
some hideously realistic dream
but the cold on her skin and the thick
vaguely unpleasant taste of maple on her
tongue
were too potent to be a figment of her
sleeping mind
she wondered how long she had been here
it seemed a thousand years ago that she
had dropped her keys in the darkening
parking lot
she thought then of her car sitting
there in its space the lights from the
supermarket falling on it in its lonely
vigil as it waited for a driver that
might never return
the food would spoil in the trunk and it
was this thought more than anything that
made her eyes fill with tears
that brought the reality of the
situation home to her
then she wondered how long it would take
before bill would wonder about her
would drive to the supermarket and see
her abandoned car sitting there
her vision blurred and the tears began
to fall freely
she did not stop them at last she cried
herself out
the only remnants of her emotional
outburst a headache and a puffy feeling
around her eyes
it was still dark in the room darker now
than when she'd come in
so she guessed the night must have been
nearing at zenith
the cold was its own presence now
closing its icy fingers around her
woefully unprotected body
and she tried to compact her trust limbs
to keep herself warm
but with little success her arms had
become one
sharp ache and she feared that her legs
were losing all sensation
she wiggled a little to get the blood
flowing but her efforts were little
better than nothing
she knew she wouldn't be able to last
very long in this state
even if the creatures did deign to feed
her every once in a while
before she realized it pamela had fallen
into a fitful dose
and had started to dream of the accident
as she often did
but just as the dream was coming to its
bloody climax she was startled awake by
a furtive noise coming from the ladder
where the bird woman had emerged from at
first she did not panic
thinking perhaps the woman had returned
or even reconsidered releasing her
but almost immediately pamela realized
that this creature was one of the others
perhaps one of the staring figures she'd
seen in the van in her hallucinatory
state
it moved similar to the woman but was
larger with broader shoulders and around
her head
its walk was quicker more confident it
also wore a long poncho that made it
appear armless in the dimness of the
loft
its snuffling breathing was deep and
from this pamela guessed that it was a
male
her stomach coiled in fear what could
she do
struggling for escape was useless and
something told her that begging for
mercy wouldn't be much help either
the thing was huge and towering so close
now that she could see its fixed yellow
eyes in the scant moonlight
she lay perfectly still under its gaze
wanting to feign sleep but unwilling to
take her eyes off it
instead she looked into its golden orbs
pleading silently
not moving offering herself to its
scrutiny and
perhaps it's pity as she lay there the
blanket was gently pulled away
leaving her naked exposed and freezing
she cried out but the thing made no move
to silence her
instead it fumbled around beneath its
poncho for a moment
before climbing on top of her covering
her body with its own
pamela screamed her breath ragged from
the weight on her chest
but the creature didn't seem to hear her
or didn't care if he did
his arms rested on her shoulders
effectively pinning them and then she
felt herself parted by a large and
seemingly human member
she tried to scream again but no sound
emerged her tears had dried but she
sobbed anyway
great dry gasps that punctuated the
creature's eerily silent thrustings
the warmth and weight of him was
sickening and pamela could feel his body
rubbing against hers
a body she almost expected to be covered
with feathers or otherwise monstrous
but a body which in fact felt relatively
normal
the only strangeness arose from the
man's arms which seemed to be clothed in
something with long
flapping rubbery sleeves perhaps some
bizarre garment he wore beneath the
pancho
pamela thought of another explanation
for this odd material but she quickly
dismissed it and stared at the ceiling
or at least what she imagined to be the
ceiling which was too far up for her to
see
when he it had finished with her he
rested for a moment
lying on her stomach and breathing hard
through the massive feathers that
covered his face
pamela did not look at him and thought
she might go crazy if he were to focus
those golden eyes on her again now
after what had just transpired between
them she felt a dampness between her
thighs
and the gorge suddenly rose in her
throat she fought hard not to vomit
after what seemed like an eternity the
birdman got up and adjusted himself
smoothing the pancho back down over his
torso
he then bent and retrieved the blanket
which he threw over pamela again without
looking at her
he kept his face turned downward as
though he were ashamed of what he had
done
and without a word or a glance he turned
and practically ran toward the ladder
disappearing from the loft with clumsy
urgency
when she could no longer hear his
creaking weight on the floorboards
pamela closed her eyes
feeling sick and dirty and wanting to
die and fell into a dreamless
disbelieving stupor
the sun filtered inadequately through
the high window and pamela blinked
finally able to see her surroundings
with some clarity
it was indeed a barn loft and completely
bare except for a few bedraggled piles
of hay in the corner farthest from her
the dust on the floorboards was thick
but she could see footprints and other
signs of habitation
imprinted around the mattress where she
lay she wondered if the creatures had
come in and watched her while she slept
the thought made her feel nauseous again
and she breathed through her nose until
the feeling subsided
pamela listened for voices or for any
sound that would indicate the creature's
presence downstairs
but she heard nothing except vague
stirrings that could have been caused by
the wind
the day was only a little warmer than
the night had been and she was glad for
the thin blanket
even though it smelled like animal sweat
she felt
filthy sticky and wished she could bathe
maybe one of the creatures would take
pity on her
let her loose for a few minutes to scrub
the memory of last night's horror off
her body
the day passed slowly and no one came up
the ladder
pamela dozed off every once in a while
her terror and hopelessness occasionally
giving way to sheer boredom
her arms and legs were almost completely
numb her pelvis stretched and sore
just the way it had been for a while
after well
she didn't really want to think about
that but what else could she think about
lying here on this disgusting mattress
rope to the wall
the prisoner of a rapist and his bunch
of inhuman sidekicks
there wasn't much she could think about
that had the power to distract her from
that
even trying to conjure up her husband's
face and her mind had next to no effect
at all
later when she awoke to a loft steeped
in shadow once again
one of the creatures came creaking up
the ladder pamela's heart fluttered with
fear
but it was only the woman obviously
carrying a few things under her poncho
pamela wondered why these people wore
those things and then remembered the
weird feel of the man's arms on her last
night
she realized she probably didn't want to
know what really went on under there
i brought you some more food the bird
woman said sitting down beside the
mattress and crossing her legs
i'm sorry we don't have anything
different to feed you
pamela swallowed a few mouthfuls waiting
to see if the woman would bring up what
the man had done the night before did
she even know about it
pamela watched the creature's unmoving
eyes but in the darkness she could
hardly make out anything at all
finally she said do you know what
happened to me last night
the woman stirred the mush in the bowl
heaped a large lump of it onto the spoon
yes she said quietly pamela felt a flare
of anger
but why did you let him do it i thought
it had been on the tip of her tongue to
say
i thought you were my friend but that
was ridiculous
these people or whatever they were had
kidnapped her they were not her friends
i just thought that you'd been so nice
to me she finished
the woman kept looking down into the
bowl i'm taking care of you
she said in a tone that suggested
correction
it's unfortunate that things have to be
like this but there isn't any other way
what do you mean no other way the woman
put the bowl down and dug around under
her poncho
i brought some things to clean you up
she said producing a small bucket half
filled with water
i can't untie you but i'll wash you if
you'll let me
pamela looked at her eyes narrowed she
wondered if the woman could see her
expression in the dimness
alright she said the woman pulled the
blanket away
dipped a sponge in the water what's your
name
pamela asked the creature stopped
scrubbing for a second then resumed
i can't tell you that she said well then
what can i call you there was a long
pause
hope she said it last okay then hope
pamela said shivering a little at the
feel of a cool draft under wet skin
can you tell me what this is all about
what's going to happen to me but hope
just shook her head and spoke not
another word
after she had towelled pamela off she
gathered up the bowl and bucket
and disappeared down the ladder her
fuzzy horns giving her silhouette a
devilish aspect
and a few hours later when the night had
reached its darkest point the man came
again
pamela didn't scream or cry out she just
closed her eyes
trying to think of her life before
trying to think of bill
while she waited for it all to be over
supposed a few weeks passed in just this
way although she had long lost track of
time
every day all day she lay naked and
alone with her thoughts
wondering if this would ever end
wondering if bill had stopped bothering
to look for her
then once night fell hope would come
with food and drink as well as soap and
water
after the first few days she had also
started untying pamela's bonds and
letting her move around the loft
though always under watchful unblinking
eyes pamela couldn't move far in the
dark anyway
though her wrists and ankles appreciated
the brief respite from confinement
through it all hope was kind and never
failed to ask how pamela was feeling or
what she needed
but she wouldn't answer any of pamela's
questions at least not directly
after a while pamela stopped asking them
then came the part pamela dreaded for
once hope left she would lie in the hey
thick darkness
straining her ears to the sound of the
man creeping up the ladder toward her
the fact of the nightly rapes had long
since ceased to be frightening
but the anticipation of the act was
murder she no longer even felt any
disgust toward what this half-man was
doing to her
for after what she had been through
lying naked in chain day after day
forced to piss and [ __ ] into a bucket
that hope brought or straight onto her
mattress if hope wasn't around
had quickly endured her to the loss of
her personal dignity
she now simply endured and waited
she was in fact so used to the routine
that when the man failed to materialize
on one warm night
some unknown time later she felt
something that under different
circumstances might have been
disappointment
she was so puzzled by his absence that
she found herself unable to sleep at all
and was still lying awake as the sun
rose throwing its sliver of pinkish
light across the floor at her feet
that day seemed endless as she waited
for nightfall and for hope to come and
explain this disturbing interruption in
the scheduled events
pamela was restless and struggled at her
bonds more than she had in weeks
picturing herself breaking loose and
stumbling to the edge of the loft
naked and dirty and reeking she imagined
looking down into the barn in the waning
daylight
and seeing a vast panorama of huge black
unblinking eyes
staring at her from countless flat
feathery faces
the image was so real in her mind that
for a moment she didn't realize that one
of her hands had come loose from the
rope
when this fact had finally registered
she felt a bizarre surge of elation
mixed with horror
she was free now but for what purpose
where would she go from here
what would she do she had become so
broken down
so accustomed to her captivity that she
could no longer conceive of herself
going back to
living the way she once had in any case
her hand was free
and with relief she shook it to get the
circulation moving
wincing at the pins and needles
prickling her palm
she then rested her hand on her belly
for a moment thinking it felt out of
place there
warm and alien the feel of her belly
under her hand reminded her of the
accident
and she snatched the hand away as
quickly as the loss of feeling would
allow
she didn't want to think about the
accident not ever again
at last she reached up and untied her
other hand cursing under her breath at
the difficulty of the fraying knots
the slipperiness of her fingers when
both hands were loose she pulled herself
up to a sitting position
and immediately felt as though she might
vomit this did not surprise her too much
as she had been eating nothing but maple
flavored paste for the past few weeks
but it was still an unwelcome sensation
she breathed hard through her nose until
the nausea had passed
after she had freed her ankles she
turned on her filth-caked mattress and
set her bare feet on the floorboards
standing was a challenge it was true
that hope had allowed her to move around
some but pamela was usually unable to
crawl any more than a few feet before
collapsing from exhaustion and
illness but she finally managed to get
unsteadily to her feet
and she stood there swaying for nearly
10 minutes
in the back of her mind she remembered
the blanket on the bed which now smelled
worse than she did
but she didn't bother to cover herself
with it her constant nakedness was
another thing she had gotten used to
slowly she made her way to the spot
where the floor stopped where the loft
overhung what she presumed was the lower
level of the barn
she heard very little noise save for far
away bird song and a low steady whisper
that might have been the wind through
the eaves
or the sound of someone breathing she
reached the edge near the ladder
keeping a few inches back in case her
unreliable legs decided to collapse
and pitch her over the side to certain
destruction and then she peered out and
down
at first the scene beneath her didn't
really register and she looked at it
blankly for nearly a full minute before
real understanding dawned
in point of fact it was eerily similar
to the scenario she had envisioned
earlier
except that no feathered faces looked up
at her with round golden eyes
they were actually all sleeping and
their faces weren't feathered at all
they were normal human faces and there
were at least four dozen of them
if not more they lay in varying
positions around the barn
floor some of them nestled in piles of
hay some wrapped in threadbare blankets
not noticeably nicer than pamela's
her breath came hard and ragged and she
was afraid for a moment that they might
be able to hear her
even as far up as she was but none of
them seemed to stir
she looked closer trying to pick out
individual characteristics among the
tightly packed group
where were the bird people where was
hope with her fuzzy horns
her odd black pupils that never moved
where was the man who came to her in the
night
she surveyed the room in vain but then
in a corner she saw something many
glints of gold like shards of amber
haphazardly distributed on a blanket of
soft dark down
she leaned forward a little and focused
her vision
masks the corner of the barn was piled
with what appeared to be owl masks
accented with authentic bird feathers
pearly beaks and staring yellow eyes
pamela had to sit abruptly down on the
ledge to keep from falling
so these creatures were not some
horrible mutants at all they were simply
normal humans who chose to wear bird
masks for some reason known only to them
to hide their identities this seemed the
most probable explanation
pamela almost laughed at her own
stupidity of course
that was why hope's eyes never moved why
she only came up to the loft at night
these people wanted pamela to think they
were monsters and she had fallen for it
like a gullible frightened child
she could have kicked herself had her
legs not lost most of their sensation
now that she knew the secret of her
kidnappers they no longer seemed so
scary or mysterious
there were a lot of them that was true
but they were just people
and as pamela looked down at them she
even saw a few young children
and a smattering of elderly men and
women this seemed she thought
not so much like a band of terrorists as
it did a community
but a community of what she didn't
really know
and she decided suddenly she didn't care
to know
struggling to her feet again and
fighting down another wave of nausea as
she did so
she made her way back to the mattress
she would need the blanket at the very
least
if she was going to make an escape it
might be days before she was found
she would need something to keep warm
food was going to be another problem
but one she would consider once she was
out of this horrible place
she'd forage for grubs if she had to
quietly she wrapped the rancid blanket
around her shoulders and tiptoed back to
the ladder
everyone appeared to be in the same
position as before and with all the
strength her wasted body could muster
she began the long climb down into the
barn hoping that her legs would hold out
she reached the barn floor without
incident and then her heart hammering in
her chest
she began to creep toward the closed
barn door scanning her eyes left and
right
searching for any sign of movement there
was none although one chubby little girl
cooed a little and turned over in her
straw bed
pamela watched her until she stilled
again and then kept moving
the door was a simple wooden
construction and it appeared to have no
lock
pamela turned the knob it creaked in the
silence and she froze
but no one woke behind her impatient for
her freedom and slightly disbelieving
that escape had been so easy
she pushed open the door and found
herself staring down a tree trunk at the
ground
several stories below pamela wasn't sure
what happened then
she remembered a feeling of vertigo and
the return of the nausea
then there was a frenetic motion all
around her and then she must have
blacked out
when she came to she was back on her
mattress in the loft
although her wrists and ankles were not
bound the sunlight glowed orange through
the crack in the curtains
and she surmised that it must be nearing
sunset so she'd been out for at least
two hours
a slight sound to her left caused her to
turn her head which pounded in time with
her heartbeat
heightening her queasy feeling there was
a girl standing a few feet away watching
her
and even though pamela had never seen
her face she knew it must be hope
the girl looked small and vulnerable
without her mask and poncho
just like a regular girl in her early
20s dressed in faded jeans that were
cinched at the waist with a hank of rope
and a white sleeveless top her arms were
folded tightly across her chest
but even then pamela could tell
something was wrong with that portion of
the girl's anatomy
she remembered the reptilian feel of the
rapist sleeves
or so she had thought of them but now
she saw the reason for the panchos
the rapist and this girl and perhaps
some or all of the others
had what appeared to be extra flaps of
skin extending from the underarm
all the way down to the tip of the pinky
like the fleshy wings of a bat or a
flying squirrel
pamela shuddered you shouldn't have
tried to get away hope said softly
her dark eyes brimming with sorrow we
took care of you didn't we
we even saved you just now you would
have fallen out of the tree if we hadn't
grabbed you just in time
hope pamela said trying to sit up but
feeling dizzy and sick
hope i know that's not your real name
but please please can you tell me what's
going on
why do you all wear masks and what's
wrong with your arms what are all of you
people doing out here
she sounded angrier than she intended
but she knew that most of the fury in
her voice was just a manifestation of
her frustration and despair
hope didn't speak for a moment she
appeared to be arguing with herself
her eyes flickered right and left
finally she said
we needed you we knew about your baby
pamela felt her breath leave her body
she stared at hope and stunned silence
we know a nurse at the hospital you went
to hope went on
seeming not to notice pamela's shock we
try to have friends in hospitals all
around the area to alert us to various
anomalies at last pamela cleared her
throat painfully
what do you know about my baby hope
crossed the loft her bare feet making a
shushing sound in the dust and scattered
hay
she sat near pamela's mattress still
keeping her arms self-consciously close
we know it had a genetic defect its
bones were lighter than normal with
almost no marrow
like a bird's bones pamela was beginning
to get the picture
and the very enormity of it overwhelmed
her she couldn't speak
when we first heard of it we were just
going to wait and kidnap the baby
we wouldn't have heard it of course
merely adopted it i'm sure you'll
understand how something like hollow
bones could be very useful to us
at this point hope unfurled her arms
almost shyly and extended them outward
pamela's first impression had been right
the flaps of skin under hope's arms
looked exactly like fleshy wings
these are very good for gliding hope
said drawing her arms back to her chest
as though she was ashamed of them
but humans are still too heavy for real
flight your baby could have changed that
when it was old enough to breed with us
but then you miscarried for the first
time hope's gaze drifted away from
pamela's face
the nurse thought maybe you'd done it on
purpose thrown yourself down those
stairs in the hopes of killing your
mutant child
but we didn't want to believe that about
you you told everyone it was an accident
and that was good enough for us pamela
couldn't believe what she was hearing
these crazy half-human things who lived
in a [ __ ] treehouse in the middle of
nowhere
knew all about her all about how she
killed her baby
how she told her husband how sorry she
was how they could try again someday
all the while knowing she'd never try
again not now
knowing that this genetic defect lived
inside her these insane bird people knew
all that and had come looking for her
the thought of it made her womb clench
pamela put her hands to her belly in a
nearly reflexive gesture
thinking of the pain and the blood of
that night the night she'd stepped off
the top stair of the home she shared
with bill
intending to kill both herself and her
monstrous offspring
but succeeding in only half her goal and
then suddenly she remembered the rape
she'd endured since coming here
how they'd abruptly stopped several
nights ago and she gasped
i'm pregnant now aren't i hope beamed
yes it took a while and i'm sorry about
that
i know it wasn't pleasant for you but
randall has the biggest and most
developed wings of any of us
we thought his genes and your genes
might produce a child capable of actual
flight
or at least the rudiments of it no harm
was meant to come to you
pamela now imagined she felt this new
life squirming and fighting inside of
her
a new life that might be as freakish as
its parents with bat-like wings and
hollow bones
a being that might flip from tree to
tree in the forest its human face
perhaps the only deceptive link to her
own species
she felt sick no harm she seized her
voice shaking
you've kept me trapped here and used me
like a brood mare and you call that no
harm
and for what just so you can do some
horrible experiment to try to speed up
human evolution because it's not working
fast enough for you
you're crazy all of you hope backed up a
little looking hurt
it appeared that she had not expected
this level of anger directed at her
and her bizarre tribe of mutants we're
trying to do something good
she said her eyes beginning to water
we've been trying to help people reach
their full potential
think of how much humans have wanted
this to be able to fly unassisted
it will be wonderful you'll see and you
can help us
her bottom lip was trembling now pamela
looked down at her body
now nothing more than an incubator for
the bird people's misguided genetic
project
she felt nothing but disgust the urge to
bawl her fists and punch herself
repeatedly in the stomach was nearly
overwhelming
but she restrained herself for the
moment she wondered where the others
were whether they would come up after
her if hope called them
she decided she would have to be quick
i'm sorry hope
she said and then she opened her mouth
to say something else
but instead of speaking she jumped to
her feet gritting her teeth against the
pain and weakness
hope scrambled up after her but pamela
managed to stay a step ahead
it was only a few strides to the edge
that was all she could make it before
they caught her
when she got to the edge there was a
single moment when she saw exactly what
she had seen in her vision
an undulating sea of round bird eyes
staring up at her from emotionless
feather-covered faces
they seemed ancient and wise those faces
we are the future
they seem to say your race has exhausted
its possibilities
ours is the new way and perhaps they
were right
pamela couldn't help thinking as she
tensed her leg muscles one final time
but they weren't going to use her body
to hasten their utopia
closing her eyes she leaped out of the
loft
in the second before she hit the floor
and shattered her decidedly solid bones
she heard the whoosh of wings near her
face and saw the terrified expression of
hope as the bird girl glided past
trying to arrest the fall pamela nearly
laughed
her last lunatic thought on earth was
you'll believe a man can fly
you